y'all did you know that on this Martin
Luther King Jr day you can actually chat
with Martin Luther King Jr okay it's
actually AI simulation using KH
Academy's K Migo an AI tutor and
teaching assistant go to chat with
historical figure Martin Luther King Jr
and then I wished him happy birthday
January 15th is actually Martin Luther
King Jr's birthday uh and then ask it
anything you want I you want to know
more information about his letter from a
Birmingham Jail if you haven't read that
you got to read it it's important big
part of what Martin Luther King Jr for
his Express in that letter you could ask
it whatever you want go on check it out
it's on Con Academy using con Migo
here's a
link